if Stargate returns or should I say when
Stargate returns will it really be a
problem that Brad Wright isn't in charge
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so we have had a lot of discussions on
this channel about the potential of a
new Stargate series or even potentially
a Stargate movie and a lot of those
discussions have been centered around
the very fact that Brad Wright
potentially isn't going to be in charge
of Stargate anymore we've known for a
pretty long time now that the
possibility of Brad Wright not being
involved in Stargate was on the cards
but now it's all but confirmed but is
this really an issue recently we did a
live stream on Star Trek where we
discussed this very possibility the
question was asked if Stargate returned
or rather when it returned would we care
that Brad Wright wasn't involved
and the answer for me personally is no
now before you get into the comments and
you rip into me for this I do have some
very good reasons why I think this and I
feel like I do have to say that
obviously I'm a massive Stargate fan I
absolutely love Brad Wright he was the
showrunner from Stargate sg1 Atlantis
and universe he was involved in every
aspect of Stargate and made it what it
was
perfect television show but Stargate is
now owned by Amazon NGM has been
purchased and for whatever reason Amazon
have decided not to push on with Brad
Wright this does make me sad because in
an Ideal World Brad Wright being
involved would be the ideal solution for
everyone involved the viewers would
absolutely love it because they'd come
back to see the show that they knew and
loved we'd know that this target
franchise was in good hands because it's
literally in the hands of the person
that bought it to us in the beginning
and Amazon can sit there safely in the
knowledge knowing that the new property
that they've just purchased is in safe
hands
but they didn't go for that option
they've obviously decided to press on
with someone else I'm going to be
playing devil's advocate here because
although I do really want Brad Wright to
be involved
is it really that much of an issue if
he's not speaking from my own personal
experiences I have been wanting Stargate
back on my screen ever since Stargate
Universe ended to me Stargate Universe
ended prematurely it was just getting
good and then it was taken away from us
all of the Stargate projects that were
in the works at the time were also
scrapped there was no Stargate
Extinction the Stargate Atlantis movie
there was no Stargate revolutions which
was the next movie for this target sg1
series we never got a third season of
the Target Universe and one of the
bigger projects the Stargate worlds
which was a massively multiplayer online
role-playing game that was scrapped as
well for over a decade I've been wanting
Stargate back in some form and as a fan
who is desperate to see Stargate in some
form I really don't care who brings it
to me when Stargate comes back because I
honestly believe it will
whoever is in charge whoever it may be
I'm going to watch it and I know a lot
of other Stargate fans feel exactly the
same way they're going to watch it
because it's Stargate I use Doctor Who
as an example
um for fantastic science fiction
television shows all of the time and I
always use the reboot as an example for
things like this doctor who went off the
air in the 80s the last doctor to be on
our television screens was Sylvester
McCoy the Seventh Doctor the next time
we saw a doctor who was in Doctor Who
the movie where Sylvester McCoy
regenerated into Paul McGann now after
Doctor Who the movie had ended it was
radio silence for the longest time we
had no Doctor Who
at all it wasn't until 2005 when Russell
T Davis a brand new showrunner took on
Doctor Who and bought it back in a
massive way bringing in Christopher
Eccleston as a Ninth Doctor Who was then
later replaced by David Tennant who is
arguably the most popular doctor of all
time Doctor Who was more popular than it
had ever been and this was under a brand
new showrunner and this is what I want
to compare it to because the possibility
of having Stargate return under a new
showrunner with fresh ideas and a fresh
perspective with new stories of how they
can progress to franchise this new
showrunner could potentially be the
Russell T Davis that we need for
Stargate and it doesn't mean that Brad
Wright won't ever be involved in
Stargate whoever is involved might
actually push for him to get involved in
some way maybe writing a couple of
stories or Consulting on Canon of the
show so when Stargate does return and we
get a new showrunner I'm gonna watch it
because I'm gonna hope
I'm gonna pray and I'm just going to
give it a chance that this new
showrunner whoever is in charge of
Stargate
has a fresh perspective and is going to
make my favorite show
even better let me know what you think
in the comment section down below if you
agree with me let me know and if you
disagree with me leave that in the
comment section down below whilst you're
down there hit subscribe and press the
Bell notification so you don't miss a
single video and also consider becoming
a fully fledged side tracker hit the
join button down below thank you so much
for watching and I will see you next
week
foreign
[Music]